We will now talk about
conditional expectations of
one random variable
given another.
As we will see, there will be
nothing new here, except for
older results but given
in new notation.
Any PMF has an associated
expectation.
And so conditional PMFs also
have associated expectations,
which we call conditional
expectations.
We have already seen them for
the case where we condition on
an event, A.
The case where we condition
on random variables
is exactly the same.
We let the event, A, be the
event that Y takes on a
specific value.
And then we calculate the
expectation using the relevant
conditional probabilities, those
that are given by the
conditional PMF.
So the conditional expectation
of X given that Y takes on a
certain value is defined as the
usual expectation, except
that we use the conditional
probabilities that apply given
that Y takes on a specific
value little y.
Recall now the expected value
rule for ordinary
expectations.
And also the Expected Value
Rule for conditional
expectations given an event,
something that we
have already seen.
Now, in PMF notation, the
expected value rule takes a
similar form.
The event, A is replaced by
the specific event that Y
takes on a specific value.
And in that case, the
conditional PMF given the
event A is just the conditional
PMF given that
random variable Y takes on a
specific value, little y.
For the case where we condition
on events, we also
developed a version of the total
probability theorem and
the total expectation theorem.
We can do the same when we
condition on random variables.
So suppose that the sample space
has been partitioned
into n, disjoint scenarios.
The total probability theorem
tells us that the probability
of the event that random
variable X takes on a value
little x, can be found by taking
the probabilities of
this event under each one of
the possible scenarios.
And then weighing those
probabilities according to the
probabilities of the different
scenarios.
Now, suppose that we are dealing
with a random variable
that takes values in a set
consisting of n elements.
And let us consider scenarios
Ai, the i-th scenario is the
event that the random variable
Y takes on the
i-th possible value.
We can apply the total
probability
theorem to this situation.
We can find the probability
that the random variable X
takes on a certain value, little
x, by considering the
probability of this event
happening under each possible
scenario, where a scenario is
that Y took on a specific
value, and then weigh those
probabilities according to the
probabilities of the different
scenarios.
The story with the total
expectation theorem is similar.
We know that an expectation
can be found by taking the
conditional expectations under
each one of the scenarios and
weighing them according to
the probabilities of
the different scenarios.
Again, let the event that Y
takes on a specific value be a
different scenario.
And with this correspondence
we obtain the following
version of the total expectation
theorem.
We have a sum of different
terms.
And each term in the sum is
the probability of a given
scenario times the expected
value of X under this
particular scenario.
At this point, I have to
add a comment of a more
mathematical flavor.
We have been talking about a
partition of the sample space
into finitely many scenarios.
But if Y takes on values in a
discrete but infinite set, for
example, if Y can take on any
integer value, the argument
that we have given is
not quite complete.
Fortunately, the total
probability theorem and the
total expectation theorem, they
both remain true, even
for the case where Y ranges over
an infinite set as long
as the random variable X has
a well-defined expectation.
For the total probability
theorem, the proof for the
general case can be carried
out without a lot of
difficulty, just using the
countable additivity axiom.
However, for the total
expectation theorem, it takes
some harder mathematical work.
And this is beyond our scope.
But we will just take this fact
for granted, that the
total expectation theorem
carries over to the case where
we're adding over an infinite
sequence of possible values of
Y.
In the rest of the course we
will often use the total
expectation theorem, including
in cases where Y ranges over
an infinite discrete set.
In fact, we will see that this
theorem is an extremely useful
tool that can be used
to divide and
conquer complicated models.